savage ac alors rapport compile tout va
bien je fais un nouveau livre en ce
moment près de mou qui se croisent
c'est à dire de vous croiser et a lâché
et ils comprennent me défendre ceux ci
verbicruciste elle et non pas et gesture
1 6 crdi leur beast 15 avec un problème
dit qu'on ferait je vais dire en cette
occurrence en cette occurrence dans
cette occurrence [ __ ] c'est moi qui
avais raison c'est moins qu'ils avaient
un point c'est tout soyons vraie plaie
mais précis raison il continua pas
exactement que les raisons et les
raisons et surtout un point c'est tout
c'est tout alors soir le problème ces
occurrences à chaque jeu sous les 2 c
est 2 heures voire quelques semaines il
a mis de ses deuxièmes jo si oui avez à
vérifier ce problème est en faute et l'a
vérifié ou s'il reporte ce prêt en cette
occurrence génère de ces cinémas coin
coin qu'on avait
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait rire il faut
mettre un kerviel oui c'est moi qui
avais moi alors tiré j'avais excuses un
an après cette évaluation de reparler de
mon salaire est ce que tu es ce que là
c'est probant ou pas je pense que tu
mérites ta direction de france
télévisions presse locale voilà on
débute un coup on dit qu'on voit ainsi
tu piges et oui trinquons convoité quand
il s'est vidé lutrin quand on dit qu'on
voit ce qu voix stupide a fait place de
trains qu'on avait d'ailleurs je
comprends brett hull m ouais je laime
d'amour sur l îlot hygaard d'otites les
jeux de 20 heures et le oui oui et ses
compagnons de la chanson la quatrième
étape j'ai mon anglais depuis dix ans
les 12 20 chaque le 19/20 sont à 3 23
heures c'est ce que pense que si ça
marche quand même c'est ça qui est
dingue les gens regardent ça ya en a
sonné
j'ai répondu c'est qui est contraignant
les champs compagnons de la chanson mais
je fais nickel a dicté je te raconte pas
bonjour tiens à dire il va bien mashable
quoi amener j'ai mené mon sac
ouais voilà tu te mets la fuite malaise
l'appareil sera là après 12h tu vois ce
que je veux dire quoi autant que tu
connaisses l'endroit ok à la muscu ouais
un petit peu oui oui oui y'a pas grand
chose
dehors mais là c'est rien c'est dresser
au rite ça va super le plaisir de te va
pardon et à maître capello cela fait une
ville
tu connais givre oui je connais gilles
bien sûr on s'est vus jobs d'urfé
capello qui nous a fait une dictée
notamment déjà je me suis planté comme
incombe défaut de la congère c'est moi
qui la veille
comment ça va jacques mon ami jacques
mon ami jean marie c'est wariner l'ami
alors général jean-marie que brive jeudi
d' le plein sur wilshere rien soufflé
l'appareil pour se prosterner devant
j'attends quand ils arrivent quelque
part
allez on va le faire bien on va le faire
à l'ouest le feu c'est oui salut à toi
grange a qualifié j'ai donc voilà comme
ça ça lui met un peu de chance et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu